you know what I hate is when they put a
rap song on the radio that they know has
hella curse words so you can't hear
happy [ __ ] song ah [ __ ] they say is
this a riddle Oh what is going on
YouTube relationships when you're a
teenager compared to when you're adult
are so different aren't they because
life experiences maturity and growers
have all helped mold the definition of
what that is which gets you to kind of
think about how you use to view
relationships as a teenager number one
at the age when you order relationship
for some reason you automatically go
full-out dumbass
cuz when you're sixteen the person that
you're with for some reason you think
that that person is gonna be the only
person for you for the rest of your life
geez the left nut to your right nut but
it to your nipple and the wrinkle to
your ballsack and the thing is if you're
not with someone in high school for some
reason it becomes your life goal to find
a girlfriend or boyfriend for me when I
was at that age I picked up the guitar
why so you get women to be honest with
you I was this weird-looking kid so I
had to do something to get them to look
at me because apparently having long
hair glasses and a pair of big-ass
titties is not the business I look
exactly like the prison lesbian you ever
had that one dude in high school that
will whip out his guitar and act like he
never knew it was there ah how's that
dude you're at the fight thing is I've
seen you what song only half the lyrics
but I played that [ __ ] with my heart out
somebody had a look at me eventually
hanging on up 6a same thing you say yeah
shut the [ __ ] up boy oh you won't be
just like that when you were a teenager
your gifts to your girlfriend were 10
times more creative it was sit there
plan that you
for three weeks ahead call all the
friends asked what she likes and
headcrab that [ __ ] like a blind Buddhist
monk baby happy birthday in it inside
that bottle in the teardrop and I'll put
those I came out turn off when we first
met
but you ever noticed the romantic [ __ ]
you did as a teenager as an adult you
just look like a serial killer then when
your kid is cute that kind of [ __ ] and
make it into a love letter but when
you're grown up it looks like a ransom
note
we have your son PS I love what but you
know we all did this because we were
young
remember when she will walk by Johanna
start to flutter and suddenly you get an
irrational boner that's like the one
thing I hate without the teeth like your
dick will get hard for no [ __ ] reason
you could be he in history class
learning about the abolition of slavery
and all of a sudden your penis be
screaming trigger
I specifically remember one time I was
in camp and I fell asleep the moment I
woke up my Korean jungle stick would not
calm the [ __ ] their help I'll walk down
that classroom crouched over and pretend
like a stomachache when you're a
teenager you have to let everybody know
you got a girlfriend or a boyfriend
let's be rid of the PDA that you would
expressed when you were a teenager was
[ __ ] ridiculous but somebody that we
thought love was running buck naked
through a rain forest with that one
shampoo commercial playing in the back
PDA and the teenager was a way for you
to stamp your love marks on your
significant other y'all remember Mills
girls in high school that would always
overdo that [ __ ] those girl might as
well been walking around with their
boyfriend's dick in the hand like see
this magic my dick and guys we're not
exempt from this [ __ ] either they were
just do it in a different way be real
fellas how many got that nickname did
you give your girlfriend a muffin three
beep aah nipple rash I remember in high
school when all the thugs used to follow
us that [ __ ] was the funniest thing on
earth but not that does don't have heart
towards weird what they fall in love
it's just what they would try to write
their Valentine's Day cards they were
still trying to do a thug style role is
all read by this blue knock knock [ __ ]
I love you that's my man
you
you know what I hate when they now
relationships when you're at to need you
when you're at Anita making up long
words that's how you say teenager napkin
I was a teenager which gets you to think
about how you used to view relationships
as a teenager what the [ __ ] you tends to
me
manic [ __ ] you did at a teenager hmm
something stuck in my teeth maybe it's a
smoothie right here what's up
we have your son boo Center Oh booty
booty